[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen die Spiele der
Fußball-WM von Norbert Lehmann schönen
guten Abend auch von mir schauen wir auf
unsere Themen heute
helfende Hände und kluge Köpfe gesucht
die Bundesregierung will die Zuwanderung
von Fachkräften neu regeln
lebenslang für Polizistenmörder von
Kusel der 39-Jährige tötete zwei Beamte
bei einer Verkehrskontrolle
und Christiane Hörbiger ist gestorben
die österreichische Schauspielerin
begeisterte Millionen im Fernsehen im
Kino und im Theater
[Musik]
schon heute fehlen hunderttausende
Fachkräfte in Deutschland die
Bundesregierung will daher auf mehr
Arbeitskräfte aus nicht EU-Staaten
setzen für sie soll es leichter werden
nach Deutschland zu kommen heute
beschloss das Kabinett dazu Eckpunkte
für ein Gesetz die Union sieht den
Entwurf kritisch die Wirtschaft dagegen
begrüßt das Vorhaben die Einzelheiten
von Las Bohnsack
es gibt kaum noch einen Arbeitsbereich
in dem Fachkräfte nicht dringend gesucht
werden ob Handwerk Industrie oder Pflege
viele Stellen können derzeit nicht
besetzt werden der Fachkräftemangel wird
zu einer ernsten Bedrohung für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland der
Fachkräftemangel ist trotz der Krisen
die wir die letzten Jahre haben eines
der zentralen Risiken für die
Unternehmen wir haben fast zwei
Millionen offene Stellen jedes Jahr
gehen 400.000 mehr Menschen in Rente als
aus der Schule kommen also wir werden in
den nächsten Jahren hier mit einem
wachsenden Problem zu tun haben um dem
Arbeitskräftemangel zu begegnen will es
die Bundesregierung Fachkräften aus
nicht EU-Ländern leichter machen in
Deutschland zu arbeiten so soll es
künftig auch eine Arbeitserlaubnis ohne
konkreten Arbeitsvertrag geben und
ausländische Abschlüsse werden leichter
anerkannt wir müssen Einwanderung wollen
von qualifizierten Fachkräften
sonst kriegen wir den Wohlstand und die
soziale Sicherheit dauerhaft nicht
gewährleistet das geht vom Wachstum bis
hin zur Stabilität der
Rentenversicherung größte Änderung auf
Basis eines Punktesystems soll nicht
EU-Bürger mit gutem Potenzial wie es
heißt nach Deutschland kommen Kriterien
sind Qualifikation
Sprachkenntnisse Berufserfahrung
Deutschland Bezug und das Alter die
Union ist skeptisch CDU-Chef März
verweist auf zweieinhalb Millionen
Arbeitslose in Deutschland wir wollen
helfen dass das besser wird aber der
erste Schritt müsste doch sein dann
diejenigen zu nehmen die da sind und
nicht zusätzlich noch Einwanderung
sozusagen auszulösen in den Arbeitsmarkt
Anfang kommenden Jahres soll der
konkrete Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt werden
aus der Wirtschaft heißt es die Zeit
drängt
woher die neuen Arbeitskräfte kommen
sollen ist offen
einzuwarungsland ist seit langem das
Kosovo denn während bei uns das Personal
fehlt fehlen dort häufig die Jobs die
Arbeitslosigkeit liegt aktuell bei etwa
25 Prozent unter den
15-24-jährigen sogar bei knapp 50%. ob
es die Menschen aber wirklich nach
Deutschland zieht Britta Hilpert
das könnte ein deutscher Patient sein
und das seine kosovarische Pflegerin in
Pristina bilden sie Pflegekräfte aus
nach deutschem Lehrplan und mit
deutschsprachigen Lehrern die
Hausaufgaben hat ja erledigt das
Deutschland diese Schüler noch mehr
locken will erfreut den Schulleiter
für Deutschland neu es sind aber die
Gesetze die angepasst werden müssen die
Bürokratie die angepasst werden muss
bereits seit 2016 ist es leichter mit
dem Abschluss einer Pflege oder anderer
Fachschule ein Arbeitsvisum in der EU zu
bekommen die Bürokratie allerdings ist
gefürchtet trotzdem verlassen fast jedes
Jahr zehntausende das kleine Kosovo
Richtung EU sie hoffen dass es nun
leichter nach Deutschland geht
wenn es hier gut wäre würde ich hier
arbeiten ich habe einen Masterabschluss
in Telekommunikation und bin arbeitslos
man bekommt hier nur was über
Beziehungen
Wohlstand und Einkommen aber sie gehen
mit ihren Familien und kommen kaum
zurück
doch es gibt auch Vorteile das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt des kleinen Kosovo
besteht bis zu 20 Prozent aus den
Überweisungen der Arbeitsmigranten und
die werden weltweit begehrter
es gibt einen Wettbewerb um
Arbeitskräfte Kanada bringt in drei
Jahren 1,2 Millionen Menschen nach
Kanada auch andere Staaten haben die
gleichen Probleme wie Deutschland das
deutsche Gehalt gilt als gut die Sprache
als schwierig nicht alle entscheiden
sich für Deutschland
wie also lassen sich Zuwanderung und
Einbürgerung am besten Steuern über die
Pläne der Regierung können Sie bei ZDF
heute live mit diskutieren um 19:30 Uhr
in der ZDF heute App und auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen
der deutsche Arbeitsmarkt zeigt sich
trotz Ukraine Krieg und Energiekrise
stabil die Zahl der Arbeitslosen ist
laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit im
November leicht gesunken und zwei auf
zwei Millionen
434.000 das sind 8.000 weniger als im
Vormonat die Quote liegt bei
5,3%. allerdings sind es 117.000 mehr
Arbeitslose als vor einem Jahr
die Ukraine drängt darauf von
Deutschland Patriot Flugabwehrsysteme
geliefert zu bekommen die
Bundesregierung gerät dadurch weiter
unter Druck das ganze war auch Thema am
Rande des Treffens der
nato-außenministerin und Minister mehr
von Florian neuhahn und Thomas reichert
die Metro Kollegah ist ein Meister der
klaren Botschaften zwei Tage war der
ukrainische Außenminister bei der NATO
in Bukarest am Ende bleibt eine
Forderung haften sie richtet sich an die
deutsche Bundesregierung
geben Sie uns die Patrick Raketen so
schnell wie Sie können denn das ist das
System was die Ukraine braucht um
Bevölkerung und die kritische
Infrastruktur zu schützen
Rückblick Raketeneinschlag in Polen vor
zwei Wochen die Bundesregierung bietet
dem Land daraufhin ein Patrick Flug
Abwehrsystem der Bundeswehr an doch
Polen lehnt ab schlägt vor das System
lieber in die Ukraine zu schicken was
erst für den 19 sorgt dann aber auf dem
NATO-Außenminister treffen den Bukarest
Unterstützung bekommt das Moment man
müsste die ukrainische Armee erst
ausbilden lässt der litauische
Außenminister nicht gelten
die Ukraine werden alles verwenden
können was wir ihnen schicken um ihr
Gebiet zu verteidigen und um besetzte
Gebiete zurückzuerobern
tatsächlich hatte die Bundesregierung
vor kurzem ein anderes Flugabwehrsystem
ihres Tee in die Ukraine geliefert aber
eben nur eines und jetzt Patrick Raketen
heute Abend bei der Berliner
Sicherheitskonferenz deutet der
Bundeskanzler an das Deutschland sich
bewegen könnte Artillerie und
Luftverteidigung liefern wir und wir
schauen kontinuierlich wo wir noch mehr
tun können aktuellen vor allem bei der
Luftverteidigung in Bukarest reist der
ukrainische Außenminister noch ohne
klare Zusage ab vielleicht aber auch mit
dem Gefühl dass ich hier womöglich noch
etwas dreht
der Bundestag hat am Abend ein Zeichen
gesetzt mit großer Mehrheit erkannte er
die tödliche Hungersnot in der Ukraine
in den 1930er Jahren als Völkermord an
der Tod von rund 3,9 Millionen Menschen
dort ist als holodumor in die Geschichte
eingegangen damals starb vor allem die
Landbevölkerung nachdem die sowjetische
Führung massenhaft Getreide
beschlagnahmt hatte um es im Ausland zu
verkaufen mit den Erlösen sollte die
Industrialisierung der Sowjetunion
vorangetrieben werden
die EU-Kommission stoppt
Milliardenzahlungen für Ungarn sie hält
corona-hilfen für das Land zurück und
forderte Mitgliedstaaten auf auch Gelder
aus dem Gemeinschaftshaushalt nicht
freizugeben es geht um insgesamt 13,3
Milliarden Euro der Grund die ungarische
Regierung vor Ministerpräsident Orban
soll erst stärker gegen Korruption
Vorgehen rechtsstaatliche und
demokratische Standardeinheiten der
Streit darüber geht schon lange Krüger
in Brüssel heißt das EU meint es jetzt
wirklich ernst im Umgang mit Ungarn
es kommt drauf an ob sich alle
EU-Institutionen dann auch einig werden
die EU-Kommission hat heute ihr hartes
nein in weiche Worte gepackt in ganz
viel Lob und Eigenlob sie sagte Ungarn
habe ja viele Reformen gemacht und das
sei auch passiert eben gerade weil die
EU-Kommission mit der geldsperre so viel
Druck gemacht habe aber in ganz
entscheidenden Punkten habe Ungarn noch
nicht geliefert und deshalb spielt die
EU-Kommission nun alles oder nicht aber
es gibt ja noch eine andere
eu-institution das ist der Rat der
Mitgliedstaaten die Finanzminister die
müssen sich diesen Votum noch
anschließen und dafür braucht es eine
Mehrheit eine Mehrheit von 15
Mitgliedstaaten die 65% der Bevölkerung
repräsentieren nun droht Orban aber mit
einem Weto überall dort wo es
Einstimmigkeit braucht und deswegen
könnten z.B die beiden Sorgen haben ob
es ob sie die Ukraine Hilfe die
gemeinsam beschlossen werden muss
riskieren wollen oder Schweden und
Finnland könnten ihren NATO-Beitritt
nicht riskieren wollen also der Orban
Frust ist groß aber zugleich ist auch
eine große Furcht über Blockade und was
dann am Ende überwiegt das entscheidet
über die Glaubwürdigkeit der EU in
Sachen recht statt Einschätzung von
Gunnar Krüger danke schön
die Bundesregierung will jüdische
Menschen in Deutschland besser vor
Vorurteilen an feindungen und Hass
schützen und deswegen die erste
nationale Strategie gegen Antisemitismus
vorgestellt
der kontinuierliche Anstieg der
antisemitischen Straftaten ist
dramatisch 2021 absoluter Höchststand
mit
3.27 judenfeindlichen Delikten
29% mehr als im Vorjahr wie jüdisches
Leben besser geschützt werden soll
berichtet Claudia Vogelmann
was tun gegen Hass Ausgrenzung Hetze und
Diskriminierung Felix Klein der
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für
jüdisches Leben in Deutschland hat
Strategien entwickelt um dem
Antisemitismus entgegenzutreten
wir brauchen eine mutige wachsame
Zivilgesellschaft die einschreitet wenn
Antisemitismus Auftritt im
Fußballstadion oder im Chat und hierfür
gibt es jetzt wirklich einen guten
Kompass den wir heute vorgelegt haben
Strategien die die Zivilgesellschaft und
staatlicher Akteure im Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus unterstützen sollen denn
die digitale Hetze gegen Juden nimmt zu
Übergriffe auf Rabbiner und Anschläge
auf Synagogen wie hier in Halle 2019
häufen sich Bildung
Geschichtsbewusstsein Erinnerungskultur
aber auch eine entschiedenes Vorgehen
gegen Antisemitismus durch die Justiz
sollen helfen diese Entwicklung der
Gewalt und Diskriminierung einzudämmen
Strategien die die Präsidentin der
Israelitischen Kultusgemeinde in München
und Oberbayern lange vermisst hat
es ist dringend notwendig dass die
Verantwortlichen sie die Politik dieses
Thema bearbeiten nicht nur mit
Sonntagsreden beladen sondern dass
wirklich endlich etwas geschieht eine
der Strategien lautet jüdische Gegenwart
und Geschichte sichtbar machen die ohel
Jakob Synagoge steht mitten in München
und kann von jedem besichtigt werden
seit vielen Jahren schon
das Internet soll kein straffreier Raum
sein mit einem Aktionstag ist das
Bundeskriminalamt heute gegen Hass und
Hetze im Netz vorgegangen in 14
Bundesländern wurden Wohnungen
durchsucht teils Waffen sichergestellt
und Tatverdächtige vernommen ihnen
werden unter anderem Bedrohung Nötigung
oder Volksverhetzung vorgeworfen
Straftaten die mit bis zu fünf Jahren
Haft geahndet werden können
jetzt zum Urteil in einem Fall der
Anfang des Jahres für Entsetzen gesorgt
hatte beim rheinland-pfälzischen Kusel
erschießt ein Mann eine junge Polizistin
und ihren ebenfalls noch jungen Kollegen
nur weil die ihn beim wildern erwischen
im Prozess zeigt sich wie brutal und
skrupellos er dabei vorgegangen ist
entsprechend das Strafmaß lebenslang
außerdem stellte das Gericht die
besondere Schwere der Schuld fest
Christel Haas
äußerlich wirkt Andreas es ruhig und
gefasst dem Urteil hört er fast reglos
zu eiskalt habe der Angeklagte die
beiden Polizisten ermordet sagt der
Richter um die Wilderei zu vertuschen
mit der er seinen Lebensunterhalt
verdiente und zwar hat er mit zwei
Schüssen einer schrotflinde auf die
Polizeibeamtin geschossen und mit einem
Schuss einer Schrotflinte und drei
Schüssen eines jagdgewehres auf den
Polizeibeamten
sie war 24 eher 29 die beiden Polizisten
wollten auf dieser Landstraße bei Kusel
einen Kastenwagen wegen möglicherweise
kontrollieren im Wagen Andreas S und ein
Komplize dann fallen plötzlich die
Schüsse Andreas es habe seine Opfer
regelrecht hingerichtet befindet das
Gericht der Komplize Florian V wird
wegen Beihilfe zur jagdbilder reif
verurteilt weil er mit seiner Aussage
zur Aufklärung des Falls beigetragen hat
bleibt der strafrei für mich als
Vertreter der Familie der Polizisten
kann ich nur sagen dass es uns das
erhoffte und auch das erwartete Urteil
war ich hoffe dass die Familie jetzt
endlich zur Ruhe kommt nicht nur für die
Familien auch für die Kolleginnen der
beiden Polizisten ist die Realität nach
der Tat eine andere geworden jeder
Polizist jede Polizistin nimmt so ein
Gefühl von mir kann was schlimmes
passieren immer mit in den Dienst aber
ich habe ja unmittelbar nach der Tat
auch gesagt das ist ein Albtraum wahr
geworden und durch diesen Albtraum
durchleben wir immer noch na das Tatorts
erinnert eine Gedenkstätte an die beiden
Opfer auch eine lebenslange Strafe kann
sie nicht zurückbringen
ein Leben ohne Schauspielerei wer für
Sie und denkbar gewesen jetzt ist
christiane Hörbiger im Alter von 84
Jahren in Wien gestorben Hörbiger
stammte aus einer schauspieldynastie und
begeisterte ihr Publikum über 60 Jahre
lang auf der Theaterbühne im Film und im
Fernsehen die Österreicherin zählt zu
den berühmtesten Schauspielerinnen des
deutschsprachigen Raumes ein Nachruf von
Pablo silalahi
eine Ton ist für ihren großen Durchbruch
in Deutschland hatte christiane Hörbiger
erst spät als Gräfin in der ZDF-Serie
das Erbe der Guldenburgs natürlich hätte
ich sie gern selbst begrüßt aber den
Schritt vom Theater in die
Fernsehunterhaltung hat sie nie bereut
noch Jahrzehnte später bekommt sie
Fanpost wegen der adelsrolle und sie
brilliert auch auf der großen Leinwand
1992 in stonk der Satire über die
gefälschten Hitler Tagebücher spielt sie
an der Seite von Götz George
meist spielte die Hörbiger die elegante
Frau an der Seite eines Mannes doch auf
Männer allein so eines ihrer Leitmotive
soll sich einer Frau nie verlassen
ich will nicht Königinnen spielen das
wollte ich als junges Mädel immer die
Prinzessin spielen also keinesfalls mehr
nein gerne Menschen die
die wir alle kennen geboren 1938 in Wien
ist ihre Familie Chance und Hypothek
zugleich Hörbiger entstammt einer der
berühmtesten Schauspieler Dynastien
Österreichs ihre Eltern Paula Wesley und
Atilla Habiger waren in den 30er Jahren
Stars und nach dem Krieg wegen ihrer
Karriere im Dritten Reich umstritten
zweimal war christiane Hörbiger
verheiratet ihr zweiter Ehemann stirbt
1978 mit 48 Jahren
den gemeinsamen Sohn den späteren
Regisseur Sascha Bigler zieht sie
alleine groß
so und Sascha ist es auch der wenige
Monate vor ihrem 80 Geburtstag
christiane Hörbiger die Goldene Kamera
für ihr Lebenswerk überreicht
2018 war das der letzte Auftritt auf der
großen Bühne christiane Hörbiger wurde
84 Jahre alt
jetzt kommen wir zur Fußball-WM Norbert
noch gut 24 Stunden dann ist die
entscheidende Partie Deutschland
unbedingt gewinnen um noch eine Chance
aufs Achtelfinale zu haben nicht noch
mal wie 2018 ein Ausschuhen in der
Gruppenphase Bundestrainer haben sie
fliegt also mächtig unter Druck
demonstriert aber Gelassenheit vom Team
Hotel bis ins Pressezentrum nach Doha
sind 95 km der flickkornwall braucht
dafür selbst mit der Polizei vorne weg
etwas mehr als eine Stunde die
internationale Fragerunde am Tag vorm
Spiel ist Pflicht genau wie die
Zuversicht vom letzten Gruppenspiel
ist es so dass wir dass wir ins Spiel
gehen und wollen natürlich versuchen ja
möglichst Möglichstes Spiel auch schnell
klar zu machen aber wir wissen natürlich
auch dass es sehr sehr schwer wird gegen
eine Mannschaft die wirklich sehr sehr
defensiv wahrscheinlich spielen wird
beim Abschlusstraining sind alle 26
Spieler auf dem Platz die
Startaufstellung aber bleibt ein gut
gehütetes Geheimnis fest steht nur sie
wollen Ihren Gegner mit ordentlich
offensiv Power beschäftigen damit Flix
Lächeln nicht schon nach der Vorrunde
erlischt
ja Sven Katha viele Tore schießen wäre
schon gut wer soll die denn machen
ja in erster Linie fällt mir dann Niklas
Füllkrug ein aber wir glauben dass er in
der Jokerrolle bleiben wird der
Bundestrainer hat heute noch mal betont
wie zufrieden er gegen Spanien mit
seinem Mittelfeld und seiner Offensive
war auf einen Startelfeinsatz hoffen
kann also unserer Sicht Leroy sané der
war gegen Spanien gut er war am Tor
beteiligt und er hatte selber noch eine
Tormöglichkeit wer auch immer spielen
wird gegen Costa Rica die deutsche
Mannschaft braucht drei Dinge Tore und
Tore allerdings danke Sven Deutschland
gegen Costa Rica ein ganz besonderes
Match auch deshalb weil erstmals eine
Schiedsrichterin ein Spiel bei einer
Männer WM Pfeifen wird Stefanie frappa
eine 38-jährige Französin schreibt
Fußballgeschichte
zweite Liga erste Liga Champions League
Endspiel stefanie frappa hat sich
hochgearbeitet
wir haben einen großen Schritt nach vorn
gemacht heute ist es keine Überraschung
dass Frauen bei Männern Spiele leiten
ganz gleich wo ihr eigener Verband
sprach dagegen heute gegenüber dem ZDF
von einer historischen Entscheidung
wir sind sehr stolz hier in Frankreich
über diese Nominierung von Stefanie
frappa durch die FIFA dass sie ein so
wichtiges Spiel zwischen Deutschland und
Costa Rica leitet
wichtig weil es darum geht wer ins
Achtelfinale kommt Vertreter der
deutschen Mannschaft zeigten sich
anerkennend 100% vertrauen
bin der Meinung sie hat es verdient
aufgrund ihrer Leistung Papa stand oft
auf dem Platz und oft unter besonderer
Beobachtung bisher hielt sie dem Druck
stets stand
zu den beiden heutigen Spielen in der
Gruppe D Tunesien bzw Weltmeister
Frankreich mit 1:0 Leben Lötzinn dennoch
als Gruppen erst ins Achtelfinale Finale
ein Punkt gleich mit Australien 1:0
gegen Dänemark das Tor des Tages durch
Matthew lecki in der 60 Minute
Australien nach 2006 das zweite Mal in
einer WM Ko-Runde
ja und heute Abend das Duell der
Weltfußballer Lewandowski und Messi
Polen gegen Argentinien live bei uns
gleich im ZDF nicht schlecht ja
und das sind die Lottozahlen von diesem
Mittwoch die Gewinnzahlen lauten 1 2 10
32 42 43 und die Superzahl 8 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 557
metrologisch beginnt morgen mit dem
Dezember auch der Winter ob sich
zeitgleich auch das Wetter ändert das
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja horneffer
das heute journal können Sie in der
Halbzeitpause dass wir im Spiels Polen
Argentinien um 20:45 Uhr
[Musik]
guten Abend der heute zu Ende gehende
November war etwas zu warm er war
deutlich zu sonnig und zu trocken im
Vergleich zum vieljährigen
klimatologischen Mittel derzeit auch
viel zu warm ist das Mittelmeer das hat
derzeit zu Oberflächentemperaturen von
17 bis 23 Grad und das sind ein oder
vier Grad mehr als üblich so erklärt
sich dass diese Tiefs immer richtiges
unwetterpotenzial haben auch dieses
aktuell das weiter nach Südosten zieht
bei uns ändert sich wenig wir haben es
in einem großen hoch zu tun das kühle
Luft daran bringt und die Tiefe der
Atlantik kommen nicht dagegen an es gab
aber heute nicht nur trübes Wetter bei
uns in Deutschland sondern hier mit
einem Südostwind über das Erzgebirge
zeigte sich die Sonne von etwa dem
Erzgebirge bis nach Berlin heute Nacht
ist es wieder eigentlich überall trüb es
bildet sich zum Teil Nebel das kann ein
bisschen regnen und das bei Temperaturen
zwischen 5 Grad am Niederrhein und minus
drei Grad im All die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen ähnlich wie heute zwischen
1 Grad ganz im Osten und sieben Grad im
Rheintal und auch morgen wird es für die
meisten eher drüber Tag sein ab und zu
zeigt sich mal die Sonne es kann etwas
Regen oder schneekriese geben und in
diesem Wetter ändert sich auch in den
nächsten drei Tagen wenig bei -1 bis
plus 6 Grad tschüss